le document que je vais vous présenter
est un document qui date de la période
révolutionnaire période qui a commencé
en 1789 pour se terminer en 1799
il s'agit du premier journal de la
presse écrite de lille son titre est le
vrai républicain au journal politique et
des terreurs de l'île de la réunion
sa périodicité et dé kader c'est à dire
qu'il est publié tous les dix jours
car pendant la période révolutionnaire
la semaine n'existe plus elle est
remplacée par la décade
il a pour devise une citation de sénèque
il en est de toute société comme des
pierres d'une voûte qui ne se
soutiennent que par leur réunion et donc
sa première parution date de l'endroit
de la république ce qui correspond à
l'année 1794 ce début de presse écrite
est rendue possible par l'introduction
dans l'île en 1792 d'une imprimerie et
ce dans le but de diffuser les décisions
de l'assemblée coloniale nouvellement
créé quant à l'idée de lancer un journal
elle viendra du directeur de
l'imprimerie lui même lundi luis del sud
qui désirent mettre en place un moyen de
communication et de culture pour
l'ensemble des habitants
les numéros qui sont conservés aux
archives départementales sont les
numéros 1 4 5 6 9 et 10 ils ne sont
hélas pas tous complet mais il reste
dans un assez bon état il est à noter qu
ils ont été imprimés sur du papier
chiffon pour ce qui est du contenu du
journal
il est intéressant de le comparer avec
nos journaux d'aujourd'hui dans lesquels
on retrouve des rubriques telles que les
événements sociétaux politique
culturelle dans les communes et
quartiers les faits divers les sports et
le tout illustré de photographies en
1794 l'actualité c'était les décisions
de l'assemblée coloniale
les extraits des délibérations et arrêté
des chaumières
alors les chaumières étaient des
sociétés populaire qui avait pour
mission de veiller au respect des droits
fondamentaux des citoyens
en 1794 l'actualité c'est aussi un
discours de robespierre d'état
littéraire ou encore des avis divers
comme la vente d'une habitation par
exemple malheureusement ce premier
journal n'existera que pendant une année
en effet en 1795 et disparaît à cause
des difficultés financières et
matérielles que connaît l'imprimerie
il faudra attendre 1804 recueillir de la
réunion soit à nouveau doté d'un journal
d'information et les photographies elles
apparaîtront en 1951